[Musik]
bismark erst ist brought you the munich
allerdings kann man kann man daran
zweifeln ob sie wirklich mittelalterlich
ist wie ich heute sagen werde
also erstens legte sie bis ins 15
jahrhundert also je nachdem wo man
mittelalter die grenze zwischen
mittelalter und renaissance gelegt dass
sie mit öffentlich oder nicht man wenn
es sich oft spät wieder örtlich aber sie
ist in mehreren hinsichten irgendwie
typisch renaissance als denken und
deswegen bietet sie eine gute station
für unsere vorlesung
allerdings denke ich nicht dass ich die
das ich eineinhalb stunden mehr über
christine zu sagen haben werde
also ich werde erstens christine fertig
versprechen in zwei wochen
zweitens ein paar beobachtungen und und
feststellungen über die unser ganzes
thema anbieten und drittens dachte ich
es wäre eine gute gelegenheit fragen zu
beantworten falls sie fragen haben noch
und was ich die antwort weiß also wenn
wenn es sehr gut wenn sie in den
kommenden zwei wochen wochen nachdenken
würden ob sie irgendwelche meinungen
feststellung unterschlagen haben
damit werde auch bei der setzung diese
also in eine umfrage vertrauen
also dieses typen der nation freuen so
katharina von siena und christindesign
erstens könnte man sie fragen was sie
gemeinsam haben ist dass sie beide in
der englischen flagge mit sehr anfangen
und einen grünen wofür ich sie
zusammengesetzt habe ist dass sie
wirklich dass sie doch was gemeinsames
haben war sehr auffällig ist und was
wird bisher nicht hatten nämlich sie
beide in der politik engagiert waren und
sogar in ein anscheinend einflussreich
fahren wir kennen sie beide zum teil
durch briefe die sie an verschiedene
leute geschickt haben also christen oder
oft kurze briefe im fall von katina
haben wir wirklich hunderte davon also
ich glaube in der nähe von 400 briefe
erhalten
also es ist wirklich sehr beeindruckend
einfach als als gebliebenes textkorpus
das ist an sich sehr interessant und
überraschend waren von ihr auch ein text
namens idealo de la divina providencia
wovon sie entnehmen können erstens dass
ich kein italienisch kann meine
aussprache und weiß dass sie wieder eine
autorin ist die in volkssprache
geschrieben hat das gilt übrigens auch
für christin die passanten die auf
französisch schreibt also jetzt haben
haben wir dann zwei mal französisch
gehabt gramm englisch gehabt mit juliana
von deutsch
wir haben deutsch holländisch und jetzt
italienisch also sozusagen alle
vorsprachen
das mittelalter ist war es ihm
vorgekommen und also ich würde
dass ihre politisch die politische
haltung von katzen und christin ist
nicht unähnlich sie wollten beide
einfluss ausüben um streitereien und
person zum streit zu vermeiden und krieg
zu vermeiden
in katar hängers fall hauptsächlich
wegen der papst streit im vierzehnten
jahrhundert im fall von avastin
hauptsächlich streit zwischen
verschiedenen verschiedenen anliegen in
frankreich zu jeder zeit die sie lebten
beide in sehr schwierigen zeiten die sie
wahrscheinlich kennen wir jetzt im side
von 100 jahre krieg man soll auch daran
denken dass die passt
der gipfel hat mit dem 14 jahrhundert
also als katharina jung war ein bisschen
erfolgsteam gebäuden würde und das ist
wirklich nicht zu unterschätzten meines
gibt es städte die ein viertel ein
drittel der bevölkerung in einem jahr
verloren haben
also von daher war es wirklich eine sehr
unruhige zeit der europäischen
geschichte und sie packt sie reagieren
beide darauf was für uns interessant ist
ist dass diese zwei weibliche autorinnen
in der lage waren oder die gelegenheit
hatten solche politische einflüsse
solche ein plötzliches einfluss
auszuüben
und man fragt sich natürlich warum ich
würde sagen katharina es hier vielleicht
ein eine figur die für uns bekannt ist
in denen sie ist ein fluss hauptsächlich
dadurch erreicht dass sie einen ruf hat
für frömmigkeit selbstbeherrschung und
so weiter
und sogar für wunder also sie passt mehr
in unserem bild von also von dieser
zusammen linie von helga des juliana sie
passt sehr gut rein
sie ist vor allem für eher der askese
bekannt und auch für die wunder die band
erwähnen werde
es ist wirklich eine erfolgen eine
religiöse figuren mit kristin haben wir
eigentlich was neues und das werden auch
einen grünen zu sagen okay wir sind wie
jetzt in renaissance und mittel heute
kann sie scheint wirklich einfluss zu
haben nicht dadurch dass sie wunder
schafft oder dass sie bei dass sie
mystikerin ist sondern weil sie wirklich
sehr gut ausgebildet ist sehr gut
schreiben kann sehr überzeugendes sie
ist wirklich sozusagen auf augenhöhe als
intellektuell mit theologen und anderen
männlichen gelehrten ihre zeit
ein beispiel dafür ist eine stadt die
ich dann eigentlich erst in zwei wochen
besprechen werde nämlich das sogenannte
carrell der weiß wovon sie nehmen können
dass ich ja kann französisch kann das
heißt streit über die rose nämlich die
der den romanen der rose das habe ich
schon erwähnt das ist ein netzwerk mit
flaschenzügen und ein text den christin
gesine angegriffen hat zum teil wegen
passagen in dem werk die frauenfeindlich
sind und das gehört zu einer reihe von
werken wo sie so sagen die erde der
frauen verteidigt gegen angriffe von der
theologie oder der literatur
oder wie auch immer und von daher können
wir sagen dass christine in der weniger
die erste denken ist die wir gesehen
haben die man als feministisch irgendwie
einordnen könnte natürlich ist irgendwie
herr minister dass sie alle geschrieben
haben oder überhaupt so sagen existiert
haben
aber sie ist die erste die wirklich die
ist die frauen thematisiert und positiv
für frauen gegen frauenfeindlichkeit
argumentiert und ich dachte das wäre ein
gutes schloss thema wenn ich das in zwei
wochen besprechen
also von daher sind die zwei sehr sehr
unterschiedlich aber immerhin gibt es
diese gemeinsamkeit dass sie beide
politische denker können waren könnte
man sagen
obwohl christine vielmehr sie kann man
wirklich ohne zweifel als politischen
denkerin bescheiden sie hat werke über
politik geschrieben über politische
philosophie die vergleichbar sind mit
werken von früheren medaillen autorin
katharina nichts also katrina hat nur
die politische ideen sind er implizit in
den werken die sie geschrieben haben
nämlich diese briefe wo sie immer für
einheit des papsttums und andere
politische zwecke plädiert hat und eben
in diesem dialog das gespräch über
göttliche vorhersehen über also jetzt zu
katharina über die ihr leben sind wir
sehr gut informiert und das dank einen
text namens legende meyer also größere
legende von lämmern von capo di der sie
gekannt hat und das ist wirklich h
geografie also seine beschreibung
ihre frömmigkeit ihre wunder
wahrscheinlich das berühmteste über sie
ist dass sie die stigmata bekommen hat
also die von jesus christus und das
beschied er natürlich das war sehr
umstritten vor allem in späterer zeit
denn diese dieser wunder ist natürlich
auch mit den heiligen franziskus
verbunden
er war der erste der angeblich die
stigmata bekommen hatte und später haben
an der franziskaner gewollt dass nur
franziskus diese wunder erlebt erleben
darf und sie war weder franz ist kann er
noch machen wenn dann eher mit den
dominikanern alliierte weil sie so eine
einer gruppe von italienischen frauen
ist es vielleicht ein bisschen mit
diesen nichts nonnen die beginnen
vergleichbar die wir vorher gesehen
haben
und die waren mit der mit den
amerikanern alliierte also wenn dann war
sie wer nichts in der praxis kann es
heißt franziskanische gruppe und die
diese franziskaner haben deswegen
vereins dass sie die stigmata bekommen
haben könnte das war es nach dem tod war
übrigens und sie waren erfolgreich indem
sie den papst überzeugt haben zu
verbieten dass christine netz der
stigmata gezeigt wird in bild oder dass
das in lubmin schriftlich beschrieben
wird
ich persönlich habe keine meinung
darüber ob sie bereit ist die materie
kommt hans was ich bin eher wenig was
irgendwelche franziskaner heute anwesend
sind
ok also erstens dass zweitens ist sie
bekannt dafür dass sie sehr früh sehr
froh war es schon als kind hat sie ewige
keuschheit geschworen und dann als
teenagerin hat sie dann eine müsste so
genannte mystische mit gott verschlossen
sogar mit er in den usa sehen konnte und
das wird alles natürlich ausführlich
beschrieben ja von neumanns also dass
das zweite ihre keuschheit das dritte
ist ihre askese das ist vielleicht das
interessanteste von der philosophischen
perspektive sie vor allem also sie hat
all die typischen mit deutliche sachen
gemacht also ohne schlafen durch die
nacht
gebetet sich gepeitscht und so weiter
aber was wirklich berühmt ist ist dass
sie aufgehört hat zu essen und nur mit
den äußerst sich ernährt hat und nicht
überraschender weise ist daran gestorben
und es war mit 33 jahre und paar aus der
damaligen perspektive war das wirklich
heldenhaft und ein ein sehr berühmtes
und der ein solches beispiel der
frömmigkeit hast du jetzt eine
perspektive wir das an wie das manchmal
vermutet dass sie an magersucht gelitten
hat es gibt sogar ein buch auf englisch
namens oder maxi zoo halle gesucht waren
und dass dieses buch nennt andere fälle
von
heiligen und waren frauen im mittelalter
die die ästhetische eine ästhetische
beziehung zu essen hatten
allerdings gibt es auch die andere
meinungen darüber haben zum beispiel
diese es schon oft erwähnte verbindung
zwischen körperlichkeit und weiblichkeit
im mittelalter also man man könnte zum
beispiel vorschlagen dass diese
ästhetische dieses ästhetisches umgehen
mit essen ein versuch ist irgendwie
körperlichkeit entweder abzuwenden
also sozusagen sich zwei körperlich so
seien durch nichts essen oder vielleicht
die körperlichkeit seite zu
kontrollieren und so weiter und so fort
wir sehen dass diese zb die tatsache
dass sie nur das äußere ist gegessen hat
ist auch auffällig und wir sehen oft
eine besondere verbindung zwischen euch
hell ist essen und weibliche denkerin
und mystikerin im mittelalter es gibt
ein ganzes buch darüber
nein namens hiv story fast von beinen
das ist ein als es ein buch was die die
branche der frauen studien über weiß
nicht ob das fragen studienkreis women's
studies der usa also das ist praktisch
ein paar war ein anfang für
mittelalterliche frauen studien auf
englisch also da ist caterina wirklich
sehr wichtig also ich bin eine wichtige
rolle in der feministischen geschichte
des mittelalters könnte man sagen ja
kann man spekulieren natürlich aber die
also was wir von ramon davon ist dass
sie sehr konsequent durch ihr ganzes
leben selbst als kleinkind könnte man so
auslegen
aber wird was interessant ist ist dass
sie nicht also sie hat diese seite also
mystische erfahrungen und askese zum
beispiel hat sie ist jesus ihr
erschienen und hat ihr einen
unwiderstehlichen mund und weisheiten
geboten oder versprochen und das ist
wahrscheinlich eine rechtfertigung von
dem was sie dann gemacht hat nämlich an
all diese große politiker und capes zu
schreiben man zu sagen hey guys teams
zusammen
mehrere werke ihre methode zum beispiel
gibt es eine sehr schöne geschichte über
sie dass sie sie war sehr kritisch über
die sitten im in der kurie der also in
pubs residenz und dann dann ist sie
tatsächlich hingereist und der papst hat
sie gefragt wie es ist dass sie die lage
an der kuhle ja so gut versteht und sie
sagt selbst als ich hunderte mein weg
war zu hause habe ich die sünden hier an
der kurie besser verstanden als die die
es hier begehen
wenn er war sehr beeindruckt angeblich
bekommt sozusagen wie eine strenge
ästhetische figur vor un-gipfel davon
ist eben die beschreibung wie sie
gestorben ist das kommt nicht von römern
folgt sondern von einem anderen
gezahlten von hier der sie bescheid wie
sie im bett liegt us buchstäblich nur
haut und knochen und also hier eher
gesichtshaut immer noch perfekt und
schöner ist natürlich aber ihr körper
ist völlig zerstört durch hunger und
also man es liegt auf der antworten
magersucht dann im gespräch kommt
allerdings ist sie eben nichts blieb ein
einstand wie zum beispiel juliana also
nicht so abgelegt und entfernt von der
gesellschaft im gegenteil steht sie da
in der vor dem papst versucht ihnen
einzulegen dass seine kunden sich besser
benehmen scheint an all diese an diese
fürste päpste usw und kennt sich
wirklich aus in meinen sie es ist nicht
nur das sie dass sie zusammen immer nur
sagt benehmt euch besser sie versucht
sogar die politische lage zu
beeinflussen und vor allem diese
spaltung innerhalb der kirche mit den
zwei päpsten päpste dann zu richten
haben das war für sie sehr wichtig also
das alles geschichtlich interessant ist
sie auch philosophisch interessant meine
antwort auf diese frage war werde
wahrscheinlich nicht sehr aber auch
nicht uninteressant
der hauptverkehr ist eben diesen die
aktiver dialog den ich war schon erwähnt
habe
ein relativ langer weg und das ist es
das ist mehr oder weniger ihr
theologisches meisterwerk und an
also mein eindruck beim lesen war
das ist ein bisschen als ob man in der
kirche sitzt und einen sehr lange sehr
lange predigt zu hören also wenn der
immer wieder ermuntert sie gut zu
benehmen und zur seite und ist es
wirklich hat nicht die nicht die
philosophische oder sogar die
theologische züge die wir bei juliane
und margarete finden
das ist natürlich nur ein nein meine
suppe tiefer ist eine subjektive meinung
also ich würde sie einladen das selber
zu lesen und service zu entscheiden
aber was ich persönlich schon daran
interessant finde ist dass die dass jede
erst die sg tisches leben irgendwie
durch diesen text gerechtfertigt wird
und hier sind wir natürlich wieder bei
diesen themen die wir bei juliana
gesehen haben leiden sünde weil so
weiter also erstens können wir sagen
dass sie eher pessimistisch ist im
vergleich zu juliane also als erinnerung
juliana war der meinung dass die sonst
gar nichts ist also ein nichts lesendes
dass wenn wir übrigens auch bei christ
bei katharina wobei nicht so stark
thematisiert und das leiden nur die
äußere erscheinung ist diese sünde ist
wir können sonde dann ansicht nichts
wahrnehmen würde begreifen weil sie nur
ein nichts ist und deswegen können wir
die sondern nur indirekt wahrnehmen
durch
das leiden und juliana ist wirklich wir
haben gesagt sie ist wirklich sehr
optimistisch dass sie dieses leiden
irgendwie positiv bewertet also das
leiden ist eine gelegenheit so die
erfahrungen zu machen die christus
gemacht hat und irgendwie an seinem
leiden teilzunehmen also man es
irgendwie mit mitarbeiter im prozess der
rettung der menschheit durchleiden für
katharina ist leiden eher ein resultat
von irrtum und falsch gehen also für sie
ist das bisherige ds konservative oder
traditionelle könnte man sagen paar
menschen sündigen und wenn sie sündigen
das führt zu dazu dass sie leiden müssen
und deswegen schon interessant sagt sie
dass die fromme es geht als kritikerin
wie sie leidet nichts wenn sie zum
beispiel harz oder mit schläft oder sich
peitsche oder sowas weil das eben nicht
aus sünde kommt sondern auch sondern aus
der welle mit gott für eine zu sein also
die idee ist der idee ist das leiden
dadurch entsteht dass man eine welle hat
die der elle gottes entgegengesetzt ist
was übrigens hier interessant ist hier
ist jetzt das wirklich philosophie die
philosophische bürger also immer eine
literarische beobachtung aber trotzdem
interessant wenn man an dante daems
natürlich ein
ein vorgänger von hier der auch auf
italienisch geschrieben hat und den sie
auch zitiert oder erwähnt nicht erwähnt
aber sie
sie hatte ihn gelesen und würde von ihm
beeinflusst sie hat passagen ihre werke
die offensichtlich von dante übernommen
würden
und wenn man wenn man inferno von dante
liest sieht man genau diese erklärung
des leidens der verdammten seelen
dies sind die stirn verdammt weil sie
eine welle haben die dem guten
entgegengesetzt ist also das heißt gott
gegensätze und also von daher hat sie
wie gesagt eine traditionelle auffassung
gegenüber diesem problem des bösen was
wir letzte woche beschlossen haben weil
ihre idee ist wer ist schuld und wir
können nie genug leiden dafür was wir
gemacht haben bietet sogar ein argument
dafür
sie sagt wenn wir gegen gott agieren
dann gehen wir gegen das unendliche gute
und um das gut zu machen müssten wir
unendlich leiden was wir natürlich nicht
können
gott sei dank und deswegen ist weg
wendel bestraft werden dass immer
sozusagen milder als das was wir
verdient hätten
es ist wirklich sehr streng und
überhaupt nicht so optimistisch wie bei
juliane trotzdem wenn es um wenn man
juliana ansgar tine katharina fragt
warum man ästhetische praxis unternehmen
soll werde die antworten mehr oder
weniger das gleiche nämlich um unsere
sinnlichkeit unsere körperliche aspekte
oder sogar tierische aspekte zu
unterdrücken und zu schwächen
si sie nimmt auch die sinnlichkeit wie
es einst walter bei juliane herr und
hier doch nicht weise sagt mehrmals dass
man mit männlichen mut diese
sinnlichkeit bekämpfen soll
also sie ist so weit entfernt von
feministische sein sagt sie mehr oder
weniger der es geht ist wie ist
männlicher als der er das nicht macht
für sie ist dann die tugend auch mit
diesem mit dieser askese dann
eingebunden
und hier kann man sie wieder mitmachen
mit zum beispiel margarita vergleichen
man sagen dass sie wieder vielleicht
rationelle von ihrer auffassung her ist
weil sie eben die tugend sehr empfiehlt
genau wie juliane und beide sagen okay
tugendhaftes leben ist eben diese und
musste zu unterdrücken und zu verwenden
allerdings sollte man nichts denken dass
das hatten wir bei juliane vor allem bei
margarete und jetzt auch bei katrina
soll man nicht denken dass asketisch zu
leben genug also die dieses käses
taximörders es wirklich nur ein mittel
um zu leben ich denke es könnte man mit
platonischen ideen aus der antike
vergleichen
genau wie die platonischer in der antike
lehrt katharina das unterdrücken der
körperlichen musste zwar gut ist aber
nur gut aus mitteln ist damit die
hörsäle dann sich auf die wahrheit
konzentrieren kann
für die trattoria war diese wahrheit
natürlich die formen für sie ist
natürlich die wahrheit gott aber es ist
ähnlich
die stets die in beziehung mit der
geschichte der philosophie
sie habe schon gesagt dass sie von dante
das übernimmt und sie kennen
wahrscheinlich schon irgendwie ahnen
dass sie die geschichte der mystischen
werke wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger
gut kennt aber es scheint auch die die
hauptströmung der lateinischen theologie
gut zu kennen
erstens kann man sagen dass sie thomas
von aquin mindestens 17 er seine lehre
an
also wie gut sie thomas wirklichkeit ist
eine andere frage
aber es gibt mehrere hauptthesen die bei
thomas vorkommen die barriere wieder
auftauchen
zum beispiel wenn wir uns fragen ok und
askese das ist ein mittel um irgendetwas
zu machen was denn also was wollen wir
am ende erreichen
antwort wir sollen gott herr blicken
vielleicht im nächsten leben aber wenn
möglich in diesem leben und das ist
genau das was wir in thomas finden also
die idee dass die zellen nur zufrieden
werden kann wenn diese das höchste
unendliche gut
erreicht und begreift und das ist
natürlich gott
allerdings gibt es hier zwei
unterschiede
erstens scheint catherine zu wirklich
der überzeugung sein dass man das in
diesem leben schaffen kann wie wir bei
diesen antworten mystikerin hatten
während thomas diese gottes wirklich nur
für das nächste leben dann ein
eigentliches zu sagen also erhöhte
verneinen dass man in diesem leben gott
erblicken kann weil wir in diesem leben
nur durch sinneswahrnehmung dessen
verlangen können erlangen können und
gott ist natürlich nichts durch sind ist
wahrnehmung begreifbar
das ist ein unterschied als weiteres
unterschied ist dass sie die beton
wärmer ist in diesem dialog dass jens
hier oder
also wird das wissen also nationales
wissen nicht der weg sei gott zu
erreichen
das ist natürlich sehr im gegensatz zu
jemand wie thomas sondern muss man
hoffen dass man die gnade gottes bekommt
das passt natürlich sehr gut zu ihrer
eigenen erfahrung als mystikerin also
sie als er würde mehrere solche
erfahrungen geschenkt und das ist für
sie das heißt das was die gelehrten an
der universitäten dann machen können
sie sagt auch zum beispiel wenn du gute
beratung haben wir ende jemand der fromm
ist nicht jemand der geleert ist all das
könnte vielleicht eine beobachtung sein
wird die gelehrten die indien in ihrer
zeit gelebt haben oder sogar eine eine
beobachtung über die gelehrten die in
harlem die seiten müssen sie es als
meinung
ausmachen früher ist ohnehin ein
offensichtlicher vorgänger für jede
ganze herangehensweise des augustinus
der text ist ein dialog zwischen hier
oder er dass er das sinn ihres herrn und
gott genau wie war die bekenntnisse des
augustinus oder hatte
andere werke zu liquidieren von
augustinus auch also diese das ist ein
modell das wir durch mitleid haben zb
bei 1 sein muss haben wir das auch und
das ist eine typische typische
eigenschaft der argentinische literatur
die auch bei katharina auftaucht also
soviel zur aktie von ciena ich glaube
sie passt sehr gut in unsere welt von
vastic rennen vor allem im 14
jahrhundert ist irgendwie gut zwischen
kita und juliana ist zu verorten uns
also um ehrlich zu sein es kann es kann
sogar sein dass ich sie eher ein
bisschen langweilig gefunden habe
einfach weil ich zuerst die freude über
margareta und juliane vorbereitet haben
habe also wenn ich zuerst gelesen hätte
wäre ich wahrscheinlich mehr beeindruckt
aber die themen kamen mir etwas bekannt
vor
ok hat jemand fragen über katharina
jemand sie verteidigen als
interessanteste aller 14 jahrhunderte
mystikerinnen
interessanterweise nichts also im
vergleich zu margareta hat es sie bei es
gibt sogar briefe wo sie sehr boshaft
geschäfts zum beispiel aber immerhin
nachher also nachdem sie gestorben ist
würde ich sie kontrovers wie gesagt aber
mein eindruck ist dass sie also
vielleicht gibt es ausnahmen vor neben
fleiß aber mein eindruck ist dass sie
immer so viel respekt hatte dort ihre
lebensweise dass sie dann die dichte mit
der moral war sein dürfte ist schon
interessanter sie ist aus italien
konzern also ja sie kommen schon von
einer reichen familie ja immer die die
ich oft gesagt habe
können wir fast davon ausgehen dass all
diese frauen aus der oberen schicht
kommen sonst können sie nicht lesen und
fragen sich einmal volkssprache und
unsere reaktion darauf ist vielleicht
aus sie können mit latein würde ich kann
nicht auf latein scheiben aber immerhin
können sie schreiben muss sie kennst
dich sehr gut mit diesen anderen texten
haus sie war sehr gut ausgebildet ok
wenn keine frage ist keine frage mehr
gibt dann geht so christin die besagen
auch in italien geboren also wir denken
an sie immer als französischer eine eine
französische autorin und das ist sie
auch aber sie kam aus italien
und jetzt also als kind mit vier oder so
dass sie mit der familie
zum hof des französischen königs karl
der fünfte in frankreich her gegangen
ich habe schon gesagt das war eine
starke stabile zeit und ihre werke hat
sind mit dieser situation immer sieht
sie setzt sich mit dieser sind so immer
auseinander und versucht vor allem die
streitereien zwischen den anliegen in
frankreich vor allem um den kühlturm zu
heilen und plädiert immer wieder für
frieden und das bürgerkrieg ausgleichen
sollen nichts mit dieser nichts mit viel
erfolg
sie hat das versucht man sieht sogar an
der an manchen titeln für ihre werke zum
beispiel serien werk namens das leiden
des krieges oder das board folgen des
krieges und einen berg also buchen über
frieden geschrieben
ihre schriftliche karriere fängt ab den
90ern oder ist oder zu spät in den 1913
199 also wir sind hier an der wende zum
zehnten jahrhundert wo ist sie zuerst
gedichte schreibt und aber dann schreibt
sie eine ganze reihe von anderen werken
briefe wieder bücher polemische bücher
bücher über kriegskunst diese text über
chevallerie ist eine beschreibung wie
man sich im kriege verhalten soll
dazu komme ich zurück eben dieses buch
über frieden oder ein buch über
politische körper und sehr wichtig was
ich in zwei wochen besprechen werde die
stadt der frauen wo sie versucht zu
zeigen dass weibliche das weiblichkeit
und die tugend vereinbar sind
sie war super zu widerlegen die den
eindruck dass das den viele hatten
natürlich damals dass frauen zu schwach
sind wirklich tugendhaft zu sein
wie gesagt nimmt sie auch teil oder oder
ist sogar der der an das auslöst diese
calderons wo sie sich beklagt über die
unangemessene passagen in dem wanderer
holz okay für heute deutlich jetzt nur
über ihre politische philosophie
sprechen denn die ist sehr interessant
und findet normalerweise stadt damit
dass sie so genannte fürsten spiegel
schreibt wir was uns einen fürsten
spiegeln das ist ein text der an einem
herrscher gewidmet ist und versucht dem
herrscht den herrscher zu beraten wie er
herrschen soll
wir regieren soll und normalerweise ist
der botschaft dass die herrschaft gut
werden wird nur wenn der herrscher gut
ist oder tugendhaft lebt und das ist
definitiv
ihre idee ist es ihre hauptidee
politischen werken sollten solange der
herrscher gut ist ist der staat gut und
wenn der herrscher böse ist
laster begeht dann ist der statuen
erfolgreich und schlecht
diese tradition des herrschens spiegels
das geht weit zurück in die antike
das finden wir auch in in der arabischen
welt oder der islamischen welt
zum beispiel gibt es fürsten spiegel die
angeblich von autos dort ließ für
alexander der große geschrieben würden
und die würden da ins arabische
übersetzt und so weiter ist natürlich
nicht wirklich auf ein altes wort ist
damals
ich mag auch nicht
und ich kann hinzufügen in indien haben
wir das auch aber es gibt viele jahre
diese legenden über könig eine game
wurde man können sie ein kartell denken
und sein hat das astra dass genau diese
idee weil die idee ist wenn wenn der
herrscher die beratung des schreibers
oder das des autors folgt und gut
herrscht dann muss alles gut gehen so
sein wobei kartell ihr ein bisschen
zynisch ist als christine ein
interessanter vergleich natürlich naja
so christine ist ist im aktuellen
vergleich als company spac den antik
indien und mag die rallye wäre christine
und machiavelli und ich werde etwas dazu
sagen ja
hätte ich das sagen wir nicht auf
englisch oder kommt doch nicht so gut an
sich ist halt diese werke sie versucht
und das vielleicht noch eine ehrung an
katharina sie versucht diese anliegen
und möchte die leute zu überzeugen dass
sie besser regieren sollen und aber
interessanterweise ist ihre beratung
hauptsächlich sei gut und dann wirst du
gut regieren
zum beispiel schreibt sie an den enkel
von könig karl der fünfte und erklärt
dass er sieben tugenden
das sitzen müssen müsste nämlich
besonnenheit und besonnenheit ist
übrigens die quelle aller tugend das ist
es ja die idee ist dass man gut
kalkulieren muss können muss die also
man muss erstens die gute zwecke den
offizieren können und zweitens die
richtigen mitteln die demenz
identifizieren diese gute zwecke so
erreichen dass übrigens eine sehr
ästhetische idee dass das geht zurück zu
der drastischen schritt von frances in
der nigrischen ethik und das ist die
urquelle ihre idee der besonnenheit ist
auch sehr ästhetisch zu behaupten dass
besonnenheit die quelle oder ursache der
ganzen teams also besonnenheit und dann
gerechtigkeit großherzigkeit tapferkeit
gnade großzügigkeit und wahrhaftigkeit
und in jedem fall entfaltet sie die
bedeutung der tugend so ein beispiel
dadurch dass sie erklärt dass
wahrhaftigkeit natürlich das
offensichtliche also dass er nicht lügen
soll haben die wahrhaft zu sprechen und
gut zu sprechen heißt nicht nur nie so
legen sondern mit elan und eloquenz
reden zu können und dann nimmt sie ideen
aus der ganzen katholischen tradition
und erwähnt alle technische textbücher
über retten soll es ist wirklich sehr
sehr gut ausgebildet in diesem buch über
frieden zb hat jedes kapitel am anfang
ein zitat
und dann nimmt sie dieses zitat als
motto für das was darauf folgt 90
zitiert ein adjektiv also die giebel
oder andere christliche werke aber auch
alles orte ließ profit wie agil und so
weiter
manchmal auch mit der abendliche autoren
aber vorwiegend antike autoren
diese breite von klassischen werken die
sie kennt ist noch ein grünes sie als
renaissance danke den einzuordnen und
nicht mit zarten ich also man kann sie
sich sehr gut mit humanismus im
fünfzehnten jahrhundert verbinden und
sich einst wirklich sehr bewusst
klassische werke aus der aus der
römischen zeit immer zu nehmen oder eben
hat der schotte ließ und das ist typisch
einer chance man könnte vielleicht
darauf ein renten das hatten wir schon
im mittelalter zum beispiel haben wir
das mit johannes von der in seinem abo
league articus im zwölften jahrhundert
etwas ganz ähnliches macht das ist wie
ein fürst des 1
wenn wir einen fürsten spiegel zitiert
alle diese klassische werke und so
weiter aber dass das würde das team
einen punkt irgendwie beweisen denn das
wird oft sollte jahrhunderte renaissance
genannt johannes uns alles wäre und
ähnliche albträumen also die man man
könnte fast sagen dass sie dieses
projekts so eine politische engagement
mit der klassischen werken der antike
sind übernimmt das ausfüllen früh mit
alten autos und will das fortsetzen
in ihren texten
ok also bis jetzt klingt das interessant
dass die politische werke geschrieben
hat aber die politische theorie klingt
ein bisschen blöd wenn wir ehrlich sind
also wenn nur merkel nette werde hätte
das mit alles mit griechenland also oder
wenn david cameron nicht so ein depp
werde dann der praxis nichts geschehen
das ist eigentlich relativ plausibel
schlechtes beispiel nehmen wie obama ok
obama scheint sehr gut um kraft zu sein
meiner meinung nach aber immerhin all
diese probleme
ja und es ist nichts klar sie sozusagen
ja wenn er nicht nur ein bisschen
tugendhafte werde werde die wirtschaft
das oder blah blah blah blah blah es
gibt an es ist komplizierter als das
möchten wir sagen und an und deswegen
könnte das ein bisschen enttäuschend
vorkommen aber was gut ist ist dass sie
es nun auf den weg diese tugendhaftes
leben zu beschreiben bietet sie handelte
eine andere hat beratung die viel
realistischer ist und vielleicht mehr an
machiavelli erinnert als an dem was wir
in der mit etlichen politik schriften
wenden so ein beispiel sagt sie immer
wieder dass wenn man denn man schlecht
herrscht zum beispiel meinen haben
geizig ist dass man dafür bestraft wird
uns zwar nicht von gott sondern weil
alles schiefgehen wird zum beispiel
wirst du kein geld haben die e mail zu
bezahlen
oder haben sie das beispiel dass sie sie
bespritzt die die reichlich schicht der
gesellschaft
das da muss man aufpassen weil wenn man
das volk unterdrückt dann kann alles
sehr schlecht laufen uns nun nicht weil
du nicht weil du unrecht bist sondern
weil das buch folgt dann geärgert ist
und dann werden sie den aufstand
abwerten
also das ist eine sehr praktische art
beratung und irgendwie nervig
realpolitik sozusagen als das was wir
zum beispiel johannes fans werfen was
sie allerdings mit jemand wie johannes
gemeinsam hat ist die idee zum beispiel
dass die ganze gesellschaft wie das ist
ein sehr typisches metapher die wäre
immerhin etwa die politik politischen
finden
der staat ist wie ein menschlicher
körper und das ist zurück zu dem fest
mit dem den fischkopf der der herrscher
ist der kopf und die andere glied
mitglieder der gesellschaft sind die
glieder des körpers zum beispiel ist die
ganze bevölkerung sind die füße weil
alles sitzt auch alles muss von der mit
von dem volk unterstützt werden weil das
volk dessen erntet für den körper des
staates wurden einmal werden wird wird
es folgt mit dem magen verglichen aus
dem gleichen grund oder die krieger sind
wie die arme die kämpfen können usw
und sie hat auch diese idee und deswegen
auch die theorie die zurück
antike und zu platon geht nämlich dass
in jedem mitglied und jede
jede schicht der bevölkerung die
richtige aufgabe erfüllt dann ist der
start erfolgreich
und man muss dann der muss man muss ihre
beratungen über den herrscher in dieser
in diesem zusammenhang verstehen dass
ich die idee ist nicht nur so seien
magisch wenn er gut ist dann weil er
verdient ist verdient hat dass er
erfolgreich ist wird gott schauen dass
er erfolgreich ist dass es nicht die
geld gott spielt nicht keine rolle in
ihrer politischen klasse wie aber kommt
erstaunlich wenig vor zum beispiel die
tun sie hier erwähnt sind nichts die
theologische tugend sondern die
aristotelische tun sie daraus der
enigmatischen ethik kennen sie er denkt
sollte die seite logische trugen aber
nur anpassen was wirklich sehr wichtig
ist und was für sie ein wichtiges meine
situation ihre werke nach dem tod nach
der liste der tugend das sind die
säkulare und besonnenheit tapferkeit und
so weiter oder ein anderes beispiel
genau wie machiavelli beschied sie was
übrigens auch wie johannes von salisbury
beschreibt sie wie es wie etwas wie er
schief gehen kann
für herrsche dadurch dass sie beispiele
aus der römischen geschichte nimmt
unerwähnt oder und auch aus der
biblischen geschichte und sie sagt ja
also jene jener imperator war geistig
und deswegen ist das alles passiert und
dass das scheint es nichts vorwiegend
strafe von gott zu sein sondern nur die
praktische folge davon dass der
herrscher sein
seine aufgabe nicht erfüllt
das ist nichts zu sagen dass zum
beispiel strafe gottes überhaupt
abwesend ist das kommt auch vor
aber es spielt eine kleine delle
und deswegen könnte man sagen dass sie
es irgendwie einen sie bildet vielleicht
eine mittel phasenübergang von jemand
wie johannes von salisbury wo gott ist
wirkliche erst das instrument der strafe
in der politischen zusammenhang und
machiavelli der natürlich sehr sehr
praktisch und realistisch und zynisch
ist das ist nicht so weit wie wie mark
valley aber ist ein schritt in diese
richtung und rückt konkret zu sein
beschreibt sie die vier gruppen die den
staat bilden nämlich die adligen und die
die position
das sind die vier geschichten die den
herrscher die unter dem herrscher sind
also mit mit dem herrscher 5 das ist
herrsche ganz oben
dann gibt es die adligen und dann die
dritte die vielleicht in den ruhestand
sind und dann klar dass also die
priester und dann das volk nun
interessanterweise behauptet sie dass
der gute herrsche beratung von allen
vier schichten dann nehmen sollen und
das ist eine sehr wichtiges thema in
ihrer politischen +4 und wir übrigens
auch vielleicht eine helle und was dem
was wir zu dem was wir in katar finden
weil es genau ein punkt auch dass der
dass der herrscher dann gratulieren muss
aber natürlich auch machiavelli also
irgendwie könnte man sogar sagen dass
diese fristen spiegel tradition
natürlich dazu likes immer zu behaupten
wenn du gute beratung nimmst dann bist
du erfolgreich als herrscher und ich bin
der gute berater
aber was natürlich sehr interessant dass
christine das macht als frau und sie
würde dann auch im gegenteil sagen wenn
die berater schlecht sind dass es eine
typische quelle von von katastrophe im
feld für den staat zum beispiel zurück
zu ihrem hauptthema fast wie entsteht
sehr oft also es oft durch laster des
herrschers auf jeden fall aber auch sehr
oft wegen bösen berater die den
herrscher beeinflussen und ihnen immer
wieder anstoßen klicks für weil sie
irgendwelche hinterlistige zwecke haben
zum beispiel können reich werden wenn
sie in einen krieg entsteht oder weil
sie einfach schlechte menschen sind und
sie warnt der also erstens muss man
natürlich gute berater dann hämmer
nehmen aber zweitens muss man wieder
selbst als herrscher wirklich tugendhaft
sein weil diese schlechte berater werden
die deine laster erkennen können zum
beispiel wenn du wenn du eine schwäche
für essen oder frauen hast dann werden
die berater dann sich ablenken
durchfahren oder essen und keine
schwäche dann ausnutzen
also nochmal das tugend das geheimnis
des politischen erfolge stuben in dem
herrscher und tuben in der berater und
was hier interessant ist ist dass sie
den eindruck gibt dass der herrscher
nichts in alleingang erfolgreich
herrschen kann er kann nur in guter
beratung allen vier schichten sogar von
dem volk erfolgreich herrschen
das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu
großzügiger überhaupt nicht völlig
unplausibel zuerst wenn man christ
cousine liest denkt man auch wie schlimm
sie ist noch eine mit persönliche
politische denker der listen die
sympathie behauptet dass man immer nur
einen mann haben muss autokratische
tötet er alles entscheidet und es kommt
nur darauf an ob dieser mann gut ist
oder nicht und das ist natürlich eine
politische theorie die wir nicht
akzeptieren können
und ich würde nicht behaupten dass wir
jede politische theorie akzeptieren
können aber milder vielleicht wenn wir
bemerken dass sie auch diese idee hat
dass der herrscher immer in
auseinandersetzung mit guter beratung
dann herrschen
[Musik]
ja das stimmt wäre also interessant also
jeden kommentar zur unteren schicht sind
sehr interessant und sie hat positives
dazu zu sagen
negativ ist so ein beispiel sagt sie und
das ist es erinnert wirklich sehr 1
markiert es wirklich so praktische
beratung was man nicht machen soll was
man auf gar keinen fall machen ist das
volk zu bewaffnen
das schlimmste was man machen kann weil
sie sind gebildet haben ihre eigene
zwecke sind gefährlich die sind zu sein
bei neuhausen die die sehr gefällt denn
wenn sie dann gerät führen können
und aus dieser passage ist zum beispiel
kann können wir den eindruck gewinnen
dass sie das volk also wenn sie an das
volk denkt sie denken nicht an so dass
es ein apfel von 80 bis 95 prozent nicht
diese schicht ich glaube sie denkt
wieder an die 80 prozent und haben was
sie genau und ich würde zustimmen dass
sie tatsächlich vor dass der könig
irgendein bauer nehmen sollen ihn fragen
was er machen sollte das nichts aber der
punkt ist dass sie es gibt vielleicht
die drei gruppen in der bevölkerung
durch sogar später auch in der
französischen geschichte kennen wir
diese idee die die es taten die estate
weiß nicht wie das deutsch und man soll
sich einigen mit der kirche mit dem
armee also mit den dritten und auch mit
den mit den bauern so sei es
mit dem mit dem volk also wenn es darum
geht dass ihre beziehung mit der unteren
klasse geht also dient die meisten
forscher sind der meinung dass sie
wirklich sehr elitär ist also wenn sie
über das volk spricht der normalerweise
sehr böse haft und was sie machen möchte
ist sichern dass die adelige klasse an
der macht ist und vereint ist und führt
ohne unter sich zu kämpfen
sie sagt oder ein anderes beispiel jeder
einstellung hinsichtlich helligkeit und
nichtigkeit ist dass sie sollte relativ
oft sachen wie man ein paar liga so
sieht nicht benehmen wie ein normaler
verein ein untertan also oder wenn das
blut hast dann sollst du es so sie sich
du sollst du dich an
dementsprechend benehmen sagt sie solche
sachen vielleicht die interessanteste
pause aus dieser hinsicht ist eine
passage die größe sagt an menschen sind
zwar alle gleich von der natur her weil
sie alle menschen sind aus dass wir
davon ausgehen können dass die tugend
oder vielleicht tendenz für tugend
geehrt werden kann und so sagen wenn du
adeliges blut hast du bist ja der
schanzen tugendhaft zu sein und wenn du
das nicht tugendhaft ist das heißt dass
du noch enttäuschender best beginnen das
ist vielleicht auch ein interessanter
punkt an dass ihrer meinung nach muss
der herrscher noch tugendhafter sein als
die meisten menschen weil es wichtiger
ist aber auch weil er in der lage ist
das zu tun weil er eben
örtlich ist und diese dieses gut diesen
dieses gute blut hat susan also sie ist
sehr demokratisch auf jeden fall
also man also begrenzt um 12 wochen wie
gesagt werden wir sagen dass sie sehr
viel dazu zu sagen haben
aber als politische frage ist meint das
habe ich auch überlegt und ich konnte
nie erkennen dass sie an herrscherinnen
denkt sie denkt an männliche herscheid
an männliche männliche empfänger also
die die die adressaten der briefe oder
diesen kirchen spiegel dieser fristen
will auf jeden fall sind die männer so
weit ist davon auszugehen dass es zu
sagen definition des volkes das ist dass
sie nicht ausgebildet sind jetzt ein
thema was ich dann näher besprechen
wollte weil das ein gutes beispiel von
dem was sie also wie sie politische
philosophie oder ihre grundidee waren
die diese richtig die die wichtigkeit
der beratung kommt wenn sie krieg
bespricht und es wird dort die
beschreibung erstens weil es an sich
interessant ist und zweitens weil es
wirklich ein hauptthema ist für sie weil
dies niemals gesagt habe ist ihr
hauptpunkt in den meisten werken oder
mehreren werken mindestens von diesen
konnte diesen fürsten spiegel ist den
herrscher zu überzeugen dass er kriegt
nichts führen soll
außer das ist wirklich notwendig ist und
auch nur wenn es gerecht ist verpönt
und deswegen könnte man sich fragen wann
ist es gerechtfertigt krieg zu führen
und war nichts
und hier ist stets christine am ende
wurde eigentlich in der mitte aber für
uns am ende einer langen tradition der
überlegung mit leute über gerechtfertigt
krieg und deswegen wollte ich ein
bisschen dazu sagen
als hintergrund für ihre ideen über
krieg ich werde für die restliche zeit
wahrscheinlich 15 und 20 minuten über
mit der arche kriegs theorie strecken
und dann fertigt sagen was ist was
christine dazu gesagt hat okay
eröffnungs frage für unser thema ist
natürlich wie kann man krieg überhaupt
die rechtfertigen wenn mein christ ist
also wenn man die bibel liest könnte man
mindestens aus und mache ich in passagen
den eindruck gewinnen dass jesus immer
betont hat dass man friedlich mit
anderen menschen zugehen soll
zum beispiel wenn man angegriffen wird
sollte man die andere wie heißt das
ja das zu drehen soll und im allgemeinen
aber wenn man sich fragt würde jesus
christus in einen krieg kämpfen die
antwort ist nein zu sein und da den
eindruck hatten auch mehrere antike
küsten bis zum beispiel julian war
ausdrücklich gegen krieg und allgemeinen
hygiene ist sagte dass christen können
in hat bei in einem krieg teilnehmen und
helfen aber nur durch beten dass sie
beten für erfolg des staates aber sie
dürfen nicht kämpfen und aber natürlich
sind originell und julian schon in einer
zeit wo man das sind dass wir sind hier
einen zweiten dritten jahrhundert wir
sind hier in einer zeit bevor die ganze
bevölkerung christlich geworden ist
also sie können so sagen zur seite
stehen sagen okay heidnische hier dürfte
die bahn dann bekennt nun besiegen wir
schauen so im becken für euch im besten
fall vielleicht beten wir für euch nicht
und nachdem constantin die die die
römische imperium
schließlich macht haben haben wir
sozusagen ein problem
jetzt müssen wir als christen definieren
und direkt fertigen wann reaktiven
dürfen und war nichts
und hier ist der erste und
einflussreichste denke wie fast immer
augustinus und es diene es ist übrigens
im allgemeinen interessant zu dieser
frage von der gewalt und
was die kirche als als maßnahmen
unternehmen kann es sich selbst oder die
wahrheit wurde dass das gute zu schützen
zbs augustinus auf jeden fall dafür dass
man häretiker einbringen kann und dass
man gewalt ausüben kann
um spaltung innerhalb der kirche zu
verhindern und so weiter typisch ist
seine einstellung den journalisten
gegenüber wo er bereit war sein
sozusagen für alle maßnahmen gegen diese
diese seiner meinung nach rhätische
christen versagt zum beispiel sogar
manchmal ist es hilfreich was man für
jemanden machen kann ist ihn umzubringen
der herr oettinger ist weil wenn er
weiter lebt macht ja nur weiter bös
haftet und wenn man ihn umbringt kann
man das mindestens stoppen und er
schadet sich nicht mehr
dadurch dass er weiters entdeckt okay
also es wird tief streng der liebe
augustin ist aber trotzdem natürlich
weiß er dass gewalt an sich was ist dass
christen nicht beabsichtigen sollen
um dieses problem zu lösen ruft er auf
die die die zwecke oder intention die
man hat wenn man krieg führt also die
idee ist wenn du in einen krieg kämpft
oder wenn man als herrsche ein ein krieg
dann startet sollte man das nur machen
zwecks irgendwas gutes und wenn man das
macht ist man so sagen in klaren das ist
okay aber wenn du krieg für ist weil du
reichtum
werden willst oder handy oder rache
haben wir es dass es schlecht also für
ihn ist die frage ob die motivation
hinter dem krieg gut ist oder schlecht
und je nachdem ist der krieg gut oder
schlecht
das könnte man sagen ist natürlich eine
sehr liberale definition des bereich
fertigen krieg ist man ist vielleicht
sogar ein zirkelschluss also wenn der
krieg richtig ist dann ist der krieg
richtig oder sowas kann allerdings ist
es nicht völlig und hilfreich vor allem
für normale soldaten es ist gut zu
wissen ob so wie du dich benehmen darfst
und die die grenze zu sein ist du kannst
dich nur so benehmen wie du benehmen
nehmen würdest wenn du nur gute
motivation hättest zum beispiel kannst
du nur nichts städte völlig sie nicht
vernichten oder frauen vergewaltigen
oder sowas nur weil der kriege irgend
einen bestimmten zweck hat wo der zweck
gut ist dass man den zweck dass er durch
diese mitteln erreicht ok und nach
augustinus werden diese diese
bedingungen schärfe definiert vor allem
durch isidor von sevilla bier und diese
doris hat einen berg geschieden namens
technologien
das ist ein sehr interessantes merken
sehr lustig irgendwie also eine reihe
von wörtern mit kleinen erklärungen und
oft sind die erklärungen sehr gut
überzeugen
überzeugende versuche zu zeigen wo das
wir sport abgeleitet werden kann als
anderen lateinischen wörtern oder auch
als anregung und sozusagen alle themen
ab weil er so viele wörter wie ein
riesiges werk wovon hier zahlreiche
handschriften haben weil der werk so
einflussreich war in der antike meinem
it-leiter und auf jeden fall
er kommt irgendwann krieges zu
beschränken
und er ist sagt gibt eine definition das
direkt der rechtzeitigen krieges und
diese definition wird immer erwähnt und
zitiert in mittelalterlichen texten über
krieg zb von thomas werner keym also her
ist die definition ein krieg ist direkt
direkt fertigt wenn erstens der krieg
[Musik]
ausgesprochen wird also man muss
sozusagen ankündigen dass der krieg
stattfinden wird
erstens das also kann es nichts
hinterlässt agreed staaten
du bist sagen okay ab jetzt krieg
erstens dass zweitens kann man kriegen
nur führen und das gestohlene
zurückzugewinnen oder sie zu verteidigen
natürlich ist das viel schneller als das
fenster für gute krieg guter krieg für
brücken krieg ist viel schneller hier
ist das wasser christinas sagt also hier
ist haben den eigentlich nur zwei fälle
wo wirklich führen dürfen und in beiden
fällen sind wir irgendwie defensiv also
jemand hat uns unrecht getan sie haben
was gestohlen oder sie greifen uns an
gerade jetzt wo wir mit man dir muss man
entweder ein gestohlenes zeugen zurück
gewinnen oder wir sollten müssen uns
verteidigen
ich glaube also selbst sehr friedliche
leute könnten mit dieser definition
wahrscheinlich leben dass man nach
dieser definition nichts machen darf ist
zum beispiel das land nebenan
anzugreifen nur um mehr teltower ihm zu
besitzen
weil das land gehört ja nichts würde von
dir nicht gestohlen
du kannst es nicht haben okay was man
machen dürfte ist der handel von dem
anderen land kommt in dein land cloud
laufen zurück dann dürftest du nach
laufen um die crew es wieder zunehmen
aber es selbst dann hat man den eindruck
da müsste man aufhören also durch
dittmann dürft ihr nicht das ganze
zweite land hat aber nur um die crew zu
haben
ok offensichtliches problem wenn das die
offizielle definition der direkte weg
fällt in krimis wie kann man dann
erklären dass 99,9 prozent der mit
seitlichen kriege nichts diese regelung
folgende antwort mit deutliche
philosophen theologen sind meisterhaft
den definitionen raffiniert zu verstehen
und in diesem fall haben sie die
definition zwar übernommen aber so
ausgelegt dass diesem beispiel
kreuzfahrt kriege rechtfertigen konnten
wie die muslime sitzen auf dem heiligen
land das geld uns das ist das würdige
stollen oder auch allgemeine
wir schützen uns gegen einen angriff von
einer anderen religion
wir schützen gott so sein weil gott
angegriffen wird wenn man so denkt
könnte man sie konnte man allmählich die
vermutung haben die können alles bereit
fertigen aber dass das nicht unbedingt
der fall zum beispiel gibt es mindestens
theologische auto mit leute die sagen
dass man erlaubt ist das heilige land
von den muslimen zurückzuerobern
arbeitet man dürfe sich nicht alle
länder der muslime erobern weil es geht
das gehört uns nicht okay also sie die
nehmen das schon ernst und versuchen zu
zeigen dass die kriege die geführt
werden wirklich so sagen die regeln
folgen
okay das ist der zusammen das erste
problem oder die erste frage über die
rechtfertige krieg welche pflege ist in
gerechtfertigt zweite frage wer werdorf
krieg führen zum beispiel dürftig wenn
jemand von mir was cloud kann ich zu ihm
gehen und sagen okay ich bringe dich
jetzt um weil du du hast mein ipod
geklaut weil lag der definition
anscheinend schon
ja also der hat was gestohlen deswegen
kann ich gegen den krieg werden
das hängt ein wissens salsa und ist
wahrscheinlich nichts die decke und
deswegen müssten die die theologen die
darüber geschrieben haben
die müssten erklären was der unterschied
ist zwischen so einem fall und einen
gerechten krieg und deswegen sagen sie
es kommt glaubt wirklich daran wer du
bist
weil die meisten leute haben einen
obertan der in der lage ist
gerechtigkeit zu verteidigen oder
auszuüben
zum beispiel wenn sie mein ipod klar es
ist nichts gehabt dass ich gegen sie
gewalt ausüben ich kann es zur polizei
gehen und
frage die studenten in der ersten reihe
bei mir in der vorlesung hat meinhard
kindler hat kann beschreiben wie sie
ausschaut
ja es ist nicht dann nicht mehr zwischen
uns und dem start und im allgemeinen
kann man deswegen nur krieg führen wenn
man eine position ein position der
autorität hat mit keinen obertan also
man wenn keine autorität über dich setzt
dann kannst du natürlich nicht zu diesem
aktualität übernehmen sagen hey er hat
das von mir genommen
also haut beispiel ist natürlich dass
könige was sie gleich lange ganz oben in
der gesellschaft der mit häufigen
gesellschaft sind sie dürfen und können
müssen gegen unter sich fühlen weil es
gibt kein keine obe es gibt keine united
nations oder sowas
eine vereinte nationen die entscheiden
kann wer recht hat deswegen wenn sie
sich denn sie sich zweiten wenn eine
behaarte andere hat unrecht getan
dürfen sie müssen sie sogar krieg führen
anderes beispiel gott kann krieg führen
oder krieg verlangen weil gott natürlich
keinen obertan arzt also liegt niemand
sitzt über gott definitionen und
deswegen sehen wir im alten testament
dass gott immer wieder krieg verlangt
also ja empfiehlt oder verlangt dass
juden krieg krieg führen und das darf er
weil er eben ganz oben sitzt zusammen
jetzt mittelalter tut gott das seltener
aber dafür haben wir den papst
deswegen kann der papst auch
stellvertretend für gott kriegführen
schlauch oder also man sieht man wie
gesagt wir haben jetzt die mittel sind
letzte frage wie darf man sich im krieg
verhalten denn es würde sehr oft
diskutiert zum beispiel kann man
hinterlistig seien im krieg kann man zum
beispiel sagen dass man aufgibt und dann
überraschenderweise eingreifen nachdem
der verein dann aufgehört hat zu kämpfen
oder nichts
und die waren die und darf wenn wir
unterschiedliche meinungen
es ist sehr detaillierte fragen oder zum
beispiel wenn eine stadt wenn man eine
stadt angreift und die stadt gibt auf
darf man die stadt erobern und zerstören
oder nichts es gibt verschiedene paar
verschiedene meinungen darüber wurde
darf man den man haben wenn man
häretiker hand greift wie zb in
südfrankreich gegen die kadetten darf
man die christen die unter muss sind
umbringen oder nicht
antwort ja wird sie sind schon sagen
dass sie neben dann wohnen
es gibt eine berühmte beispiel ein gutes
beispiel wo die kreuzfahrt kriege haben
die die haben eine eine krieg in der
machts genommen und der general würde
gefragt wie sie die häretiker finden
sollten um sie umzubringen und hat
gesagt alle umbringen gott wird seine
zeit in erkennen dass man auch aus
diesen texten dann entnehmen kann ist
dass die normale soldaten und anliegen
die wirklich ausgeführt haben waren
anscheinend sehr nervös dass sie
vielleicht in die hölle kommen wegen
ihrer verwaltung im krieg wenn man diese
geschichten hört ist kein wunder
und es gibt eine reihe von theologischen
werken und bergwerken der beratung
einschließlich die werke die christine
scheid die erklären was man machen muss
nicht machen muss sozusagen schuldlos
von kriegs nach hause zu kommen kommen
zu können
und das sehr was hier ist sehr auffällig
ist dass die die hauptströmung in der
tradition ist zu sagen
keine sorge der herrscher ist eigentlich
schuld also wenn der herrscher denn wenn
der könig oder der imperator wenn er
sich entscheidet kriegsschiffen müssen
alle seine untertanen für ihn kämpfen
das ist natürlich grundsätzlich mit der
gesellschaft und wenn er das wenn er so
entscheidet auch wenn er unrecht hat
bist du nicht schon zwar weil du hast
die aufgabe für ihn zu kämpfen dass es
deine aufgabe seine aufgabe ist zu
entscheiden ob man kämpfen soll oder
nicht
das in einem krieg in einem unrecht im
krieg kann man mit gerechtigkeit selber
kämpfen weil der königsschuss run ist
dass der krieg stattfindet nicht du als
zutat alles was du machen musst ist
schauen dass du nichts
das werden des krieges unangemessen
gewalttätig camps zum beispiel an frauen
oder kinder umbringen im krieg das darf
man nichts weil man eben die die gute
zwecke da nicht erreicht und deswegen
könnte könnte man sagen dass diese
ursprüngliche idee dass die gute
zweckel motivation die hinter dem guten
krieg steckt das sollte nach der meinung
die die theologen sichern dass man schon
floss durch den krieg kommt selbst als
zutat okay was sagt christine zu diese
fragen erst im allgemeinen den hightech
es wahrscheinlich schon gegeben aber das
möchte ich betonen sie ist es die vier
sänger gegen krieg als all diese
aggregatoren also eher punkt wenn sie
krieg diskutiert ist irgendwas zu sagen
warum das nicht man das nicht machen
soll also der die einstellung ist nicht
dort dürft wahrscheinlich krieg führen
aber es gibt ein paar auf es gibt ein
paar ausnahmen
er ist ihr deutsch schafft man sollte
eigentlich fast nie krieg führen und
nicht nur weil es ungerecht ist oft das
ist sie auch
aber weil es eine schlechte idee ist das
nochmal die der schritt in richtung
machiavelli also kriegt sie sie abwartet
krieg zu führen
nicht nur weil krieg eine sünde ist das
auch aber weil die wirklich sehr sehr
gefährlich ist für den staat und das
erklärt sie durch die sehr alt dass das
alte thema von glück und fortuna im
krieg wenn es die sachs haben zum
beispiel jeder herrscher sei er auch so
stark ist wecker als glück also du
kannst eine einen armee haben der
dreimal so groß ist wie der gegnerischen
an
und trotzdem verlieren weil es immer ein
glücksspiel krieg und das was sie ihrer
meinung nach sind die herrscher die
kriege führen fast immer fast immer zu
viel selbstbewusstsein also sind wir
zuversichtlich und denken ja natürlich
geben ich habe
sobald man zusammen
auf diesen auf diesen weg dann fährt
kann man keine ahnung was passieren
könnte es immer besser die zwecke durch
diplomatie zu erreichen
erstens dass zweitens sie wiederholt all
diese alte regelungen für krieg also nur
nur um das gestohlene sachen ist
zurückzuerobern
über und rechts direkt kontakt zu
beschaffen und so weiter also sagt sie
alles aber sie fühlt etwas anderes sind
super sehr interessant ist und es geht
zurück zu dem was ich vorher gesagt habe
über beratung wie sie sagt ein ein krieg
zu führen muss
der herrscher zwei sachen tun er muss
beratung nehmen von guten beratern und
implizit ist hier wahrscheinlich die
idee gute berater werden immer abraten
krieg zu führen
also man muss so sein berater haben die
dazu neigen immer so denken creed ist
nur was das wir uns erlauben wenn es
wirklich anders überhaupt nicht geht
also erstens sollte man das machen und
zweitens wir nehmen hier an
wir führen nur kriege wenn der feind
irgendein unrecht getan hat und deswegen
muss man den feind die gelegenheits
anbieten sich selbst so bereich fertigen
also muss die chance haben so erklären
warum er gemacht hat das was er gemacht
hat
nur wenn er das nicht nicht überzeugend
rechtfertigen kann
und nur wenn diese frieden
der berater selbst die wenn sie auch
fähig empfehlen dann kann man krieg
führen so hier ist entweder ersten drei
sachen erst was ich schon gesagt habe
der herrscher soll so nicht einfach im
alleingang entscheiden
da denke ich immer an das was george hw
bush gesagt hat ein mittel sein
als ich entscheide mich das ist positiv
also er muss irgendwie muss er
entscheiden
aber er muss mit einer gruppe von
kundenberatern entscheiden und nicht nur
zusammen nach gefühl führen wie er
gemacht hat
erstens dass zweitens will ist sie den
herrscher wirklich zu sagen entlassen
mit diesen regelungen die krieg sehr
unwahrscheinlich machen
und drittens ist und das ist ab sagte
was sie hier empfiehlt ist dass man das
gute krieg ist nicht nur hat nicht nur
damit zu tun dass die zwecke des krieges
gut sind oder das ist ein harter casus
belli gibt also ursache des krieges das
gebot nichts man muss auch die richtige
methode benutzen oder man muss nur den
richtigen prozess arbeiten bevor man
liefert zum beispiel das könnte man
vielleicht mit dem mit der jetzigen idee
dass ein land nur direkt hat krieg zu
führen wenn der krieg irgendwie legal
ist natürlich übertrieben zu sagen dass
sie ihren eine ahnung von von
internationalem gesetz oder so was aber
wirklich es ist wirklich sehr auffällig
dass sie nicht nur dass sie direkt
fertigte kriegen nicht nur durch zb
zwecke oder sowas definiert wie wir
vorher in der der installation haben
sondern auch dadurch dass man nur zum
krieg kommt durch eine überlegung des
prozess was selbst irgendwie den krieg
auch mit
werk fertigt das ist wirklich sehr
interessant also es nichts nicht ohne
grund wird sie nicht nur als also
natürlich ist sie eine sehr interessante
denkerin und unter denker ihr derzeit
weil sie weiblich ist was sehr auffällig
ist und so weiter aber es die es ab frau
oder mann ist sie wirklich eine
interessante denken in der geschichte
der politischen klasse wie es zum
beispiel wenn ich vorlesungen über
politische philosophie von was weiß ich
alles sollte nicht so hopps oder sowas
wer nicht das unterrichten würde würde
ich auf jeden fall christin die sagen
dann auch abdecken wollen wir sind mit
ihr noch nicht fertig in zwei wochen
werde ich ihr die ansichten über frauen
besprechen nächste woche kommt professor
doktor modelle also nicht verpassen und
aber wir sehen uns in zwei wochen
total zieht sie wird